let's get into this crypto winter it's
been now when did it peak December I
have no sense of the timeline on it 2019
it peaked in 2017 in the in the
Christmas or was it yeah so now we're
over a year since the dagger Sabu burger
right since yeah yeah
it peaked in December two December's ago
so we're now 18 months after this is
there anything that's gonna come out of
this and how will we look back at this I
mean I think there are people still
working hard on this right on various
aspects of this I have exactly one
crypto investment in a stable coin
company I think there's a real problem
they can solve there yeah but you know
I've sort of said you're gonna solve
interesting problems by slaughtering
some of these sacred cows and the
religion of crypto right and so that one
it's like look you're gonna take a bunch
of dollars and put them in the bank and
crypto people lose their mind when you
start talking about that but actually it
turns out there are a set of real
problems you can solve for real people
that way I see you know as I talk to
crypto founders like they're out there
still buildings you you forget they
raised hundreds of millions of dollars
yo its raised billions yeah yeah Tazo so
I think you thought yeah they raised a
hundred or two hundred million I mean
they've got a team sitting in France
just building software so I like that
the I I've always felt like the market
cap thing was a bug right we all lost
our minds on this pyramid scheme yeah
and what was interesting was the
underlying technology so I think
actually the bear market accelerates the
technology because it gets rid of all of
this noise distraction noise so we'll
see we'll see what happened and the sec
is coming down on a couple of these as
well and made them reverse it which is
great I mean they should put all those
people in jail yeah I want to speak
counter to that though I mean if you
have a hundred million dollars in the
bank and really like nobody's paying
attention what are you building and why
and perfectly fair right don't leave I
mean like that is that is for me as like
a serial entrepreneur like that is the
worst case yes not just over funding
what you're doing but so massively
over funding what you're doing that like
literally no one ever even has to work
again yeah what are we even doing with
our time I mean I think that's totally
fair I mean my critique of this funding
model was that we've gone back to
waterfall development right so for folks
you know who have had not gone through
the software development lifecycle in
the olden days of yore we would write
the spec and then we build for five
years and then we'd ship something and
know if anybody wanted it waterfall we
decided that was a bad idea
all right so startups move towards this
rapid iteration shipping code all the
time learning all the time in crypto
especially with the you know the big
fundraiser up front is this let's just
build for five years off your built
protocol and yeah welcome that's it so I
think that's totally fair but at the
same time there's people sitting in a
dark room somewhere building things and
maybe something will come up at least
they're not being distracted by like
there was a period where everybody was
quitting their jobs because they just
had a bunch of aetherium and they're
like I guess I'm calling in rich now
that's gone away which is positive yeah
it was very troubling for me you know
having worked with AngelList and doing
angel investing how many funds to watch
people do securities offerings without
any consideration like in the early days
of AngelList and we're doing the
Syndicates we're sitting there thinking
about every aspect of how to do this
right and do right by the founder and do
right by the LPS and the syndicate
members and I just remember these early
days of navall and I talking like should
we do a company that's pre product
market fit should we do a bridge okay
how many months would this bridge last
okay let's set the bridge if they're
gonna do it at 12 months let's make sure
we put that into the documents so that
people who are you know and we really
were thinking beyond whatever the SEC
said we were just thinking what would
make the investor on the other side feel
better like so yeah I mean and these
guys were doing two for 1,000 well I
think the bigger Ty's problem that I had
with it was that there was this lie that
was like this is the democratization of
this stuff and when in fact what you saw
was all the traditional investors front
running these things getting in at low
prices and then we'd go out to the
public with these thing
and pretend that they were getting a
great deal on them I think what you're
gonna see in the next wave if there's a
next wave as these things are gonna look
much more like traditional venture
realms and that's gonna be better for
the companies that's gonna be better for
the teams and people who are angsty
about you know accreditation rules are
just gonna have to kind of deal with
that